wait-wait-wait-wait  [Music]  work ethic just go to City College and  then to jail and then back to City  College and then maybe you'd learn to  pull yourself up and not expect  everybody everything I said of course  not you drilled holes into Dennis  doesn't he know I didn't  play that again play what again the  thing you played outside oh you want me  to play the thing I played outside  please you have to know with me yes you  practically see it from here what oh oh  gosh oh gosh because you know the  position that would put me in you know  we have language in the Prospectus yeah  I know I know that the Badgers can  change their mind that's and I know what  is at stake  [Music]  [Music]  you